empty supermarket shelves gas pumps gone
dry britain's current shortages remind
some stalwart citizens of wartime
hardship a drastic lack of truck drivers
has blocked deliveries of gasoline and
food one reason post-brexit cutbacks on
visas for foreign labor brexiteer boris
johnson denies brexits to blame at their
recent conference torres called the
current strains a sign of economic
revival and vowed to look beyond europe
for new friends
our topic today boris brexit boomerang
is the uk spiraling into chaos
[Music]
hello and welcome to to the point it's a
pleasure to welcome our guests vandaline
fun brado is the berlin-based
correspondent for the british weekly the
economist and she says boris johnson
famously wrote two newspaper columns
arguing for and against brexit just
before the referendum he must deeply
regret sending the wrong one
it's also a pleasure to welcome john
worth he's a british freelance
journalist and blogger his opinion
brexit didn't cause the problems the uk
is currently facing but it has removed
many of the means britain had to solve
those problems
and i'm very glad to have my colleague
simon young a political correspondent
for deutsche bella on the show he says
boris johnson says the problem actually
shows the u.s the uk economy is strong
but many britons doubt he has a plan to
deal with the problems
vandaling you say the prime minister has
cause to regret his post-brexit uh
pro-brexit enthusiasm is public opinion
turning against brexit what are you
seeing in the polls
no not yet i mean not the not the the
people who supported brexit in the first
place um but
i feel we are seeing a sort of parallel
word if you look at the pictures from
the tory party conference you know they
were dancing the night away and there's
a very good upbeat mood but then if you
look at the rest of the country you know
the empty shelves the queues at the
petrol station
people are upset and people are angry
but the in general public opinion is
still
he's still very popular the prime
minister so it's not turning yet
although john in fact there is one poll
that's just come out from yougov showing
a slim majority 53 percent of those
polled saying that in fact uh they now
see more downside from brexit than
upside you say that brexit didn't cause
the problems the uk is facing so would
you say people are drawing the
wrong conclusions if they if they say
this is the downside if you unpick that
a little bit essentially the british are
saying hang on a minute maybe brexit
itself is not the problem perhaps it's
the way that boris johnson is doing it
right now
i would say that there was probably no
good brexit to be had but theoretically
maybe a brexit was not quite as damaging
as this one would have been possible
um
what you have to bear in mind is that
these shortages of labor in the british
labor market they have not just suddenly
come about in the last six months
britain has not been um
training enough truck drivers enough
doctors enough nurses for two decades
now and the the uk could plug the gaps
in its labor market with labor from
other european countries now out of the
european union it can no longer do that
but these problems predate brexit by
quite some years it's just we're seeing
the consequences now and so of course
the fact that britain is hit harder than
other european countries of course is
then in the public debate somewhat
connected to brexit so simon your
opening statement said that uh
people question whether the prime
minister has a plan but in fact he gave
a rousing speech at this week's tory
party conference saying that the fuel
shortages are proof that the plan is
working so to speak that they're part of
a glorious high-wage
future uh is that convincing
well they the government's got this sort
of complex narrative that uh you know
they went into covid pretty much at the
same time as uh as the brexit uh as
brexit happened
and uh now things are coming back on
stream there's surging demand
and because there's been sort of lumpy
uh uh consumer demand during the the
covid 19 crisis um you know now we're
seeing surging demands and that you know
that the the problems are proof of it um
well is it convincing i don't know i
think as wendelin said
you know there's going to be a lot of
people who are losing confidence who
will lose confidence if this crisis
continues uh particularly in the run-up
to christmas if british people can't get
their turkeys uh in time for christmas
that's going to cause trouble
and let's dig a bit deeper in fact
on the crisis and the outlook some
economists are calling the fuel crisis a
warning sign for the country's economy
overall
could the costs of brexit prove higher
than tory brexiteers claimed
empty gas pumps and long queues outside
the service stations that still have
fuel
great britain is in a state of chaos
with an estimated shortage of 100 000
truck drivers the supply of much needed
gasoline is running dry
just frustrating i just want to be able
to get fuel and go to work
suddenly all these drivers were missing
where have they all gone back to the eu
so
yeah no it's not really very good to be
honest it's chaos
absolute chaos
supermarket shelves across the country
lie empty too this is due to a shortage
of cheap labor from the eu as a result
of brexit
other sectors of the economy have also
been affected they include the service
sector skilled trade and agriculture
we've lost the type of labour that made
the uk really strong
they've gone back to europe they're
going to make europe strong
cam boris johnson and his tourists get a
grip on the brexit mess
let me pass that question straight on uh
to you john in fact the fuel shortages
are easing somewhat now that the
government has called in the army to
help deliver petrol so does the
government now have things under control
would you say i'm not sure the
government does have things under
control because there are multiple
crises here as your report adequately
demonstrated indeed there are a few
other things you could have additionally
mentioned there's some difficulties in
in the
farming industries for example or even
getting chemicals for for processing
sewage so that all kinds of difficulties
right across the economy but for me the
really interesting point is short term
versus long term
there are labor shortages which we know
about right now so if you patch it up
for delivery of petrol to fueling
stations you're potentially going to
cause a bit of a problem more that's
more severe for the delivery for your
supermarket and to train new truck
drivers is going to take months to train
new veterinary surgeons or to train new
doctors is going to take years so to get
to this kind of promise new land that
boris johnson is talking about that's
going to take a long time and it's going
to be very problematic in that interim
period so i don't think the british
government has a plan at all the idea of
managing to recruit truck drivers to
sort out their shortage the times
newspaper this week reported they
recruited just 27 new truck drivers
that's going to be a drop in the ocean
and with regard to the thousands that
they're short vandaline uh certainly
your newspaper the economist has cast
doubt on whether there's a convincing
plan wages for truck drivers though have
in fact taken a sharp upturn in the
course of this year so is the labor
market responding are british citizens
now jumping in to fill those jobs well
they're still not jumping in wages have
been rising and there is a shortage of
lorry drivers everywhere in
in in europe and in britain only in
europe you can compensate more easily
because you know they can move from one
country to the other and and basically
alleviate the most acute shortages
the thing is truck driving is a very not
that i've ever done it but from reports
i know it's a very very tough job and
it's not very attractive so there's
still an acute shortage and maybe wages
have to rise even more just because it's
such a hard job
so simon the government has also now
expanded the uh contingent of allowed
visas for foreign drivers will that
solve the problem
uh well it could do i uh hear that
bulgarian truck drivers are saying you
know they they might be tempted back but
uh actually there's a problem in
bulgaria as well they haven't got enough
truck drivers there so
as was said freedom of movement is one
way to solve this but we don't have
freedom of movement between the eu and
the uk anymore uh it's a drop in the
ocean i think the figure given is a
hundred thousand truck drivers who who
who are missing as it were who are
needed
how to get them back in partly it's also
a problem by the way of uh of an aging
workforce people have been dropping out
it's a structural problem the government
could have had a role in solving it not
only the government i suppose industry
as well um and
you know
boris johnson and his government are
relying on industry to on the logistics
industry uh to uh to solve this problem
but the road haulage association that
kind of the the association for for this
industry has been screaming about this
problem for years saying we've got these
difficulties we need to overcome those
problems and the government has not been
listening
and so that's why i ultimately conclude
this is too little too late and that's
why this problem one way or another even
if we solve it in the fueling stations
the impacts are going to be felt across
the rest of the the economy for some
time to come certainly the those in the
industry are still very concerned that
even if we solve it right now for the
fueling stations the problems will
persist and in fact it's not only
businesses in that sector that are
complaining but we're hearing a lot of
complaints you mentioned farmers earlier
on labor shortages at slaughterhouses
are also generating some very bloody
media reporting with pig farmers
apparently culling their herds and
killing healthy animals because they
can't send the ones they intended to to
the slaughterhouses what do you think
this means longer term is the government
going to have to water down its
anti-immigration stance that was part of
brexit
we don't quite know at the moment it's
slightly strange because the government
at the moment has managed to more or
less annoy everyone um it's
somewhat anti-immigration voters now see
that maybe the government is opening up
a bit again by with with this emergency
visa scheme for truck drivers the
farmers might potentially be next um
while at the same time
the anti-immigration sentiment in the uk
and indeed labor shortages as we've just
been talking about in other european
countries will say okay if i could
potentially choose as a worker would i
like to stay in germany or in france or
go to the uk
for a short period of time where my my
position in that job would not be
guaranteed i think the british
government have to do quite a lot more
to persuade a lot of those eu workers
back to the uk than it's been than it's
done so far and vandalin if we look at
the numbers i mean as far as i know the
expanded contingent uh is something like
5 000 visas that's just a symbolic
gesture a drop in the bucket it's not
only us but it's not enough for sure but
it's also not a very attractive
proposition it's a it's a temporary visa
for i think three months and um and and
for not enough people you know why why
would you leave your job in poland or in
bulgaria to return to the uk for three
months and you have to go back i don't
think it will work at all and i think
they i think they may even drop the plan
simon
anti-immigration policy it was an
absolute pillar of brexit
is it a red line do you think still for
the conservatives or do you think that
they may wind up retracting
some of this in the face of
an economic downturn potentially well as
you've already said they have relaxed it
they've they've offered these uh a few
thousand million
a minimal relaxation but that's kind of
the new narrative they want to tell
boris johnson says we don't want to be a
low-wage low-skill economy and we don't
want to fuel low wages and low skills
with immigration that's what the way he
tells it so
we we don't want immigration we want uh
you know our own workforce to do do the
high-skilled jobs it's a little unclear
how that marries as you said with with
uh truck driving which uh is not
regarded anyway as a high skilled
profession uh but also the the story of
of being able to change the rules around
immigration rather nimbly if i can use a
a a key word that the the brexit
supporters have always said that britain
would be more nimble in its regulation
in future that is something that they're
quite proud of being able to do actually
so they can tell a positive story uh
boris johnson's good for those but
that's not true ultimately right you
basically had a pool of labor of a few
hundred million workers you could
potentially call on that was as nimble
as you could possibly imagine someone
can basically move on their own back
from one country to another another
problem solved it's taken months of the
the the haulage industry screaming to
say we need more truckers to get the
british government to actually act and
then they've only done too little too
late so this is the very opposite of
nimble right they're basically the
restrictions they put in place have
actually
made the problem harder to solve while
at the same time they're saying actually
this is this is proof of the great kind
of post-brexit world it doesn't actually
add up britain benefited from freedom of
movement but no politicians are honest
enough to actually say that upfront
vendeline let me ask you how nimble you
think the british government can be in
dealing with some of the other
brexit-related problems that are coming
its way
first of all french fishermen with
france saying it may retaliate against
the uk for the fact that apparently the
uk is not granting as many fishing
licenses to the french as it had
promised in the brexit negotiations
secondly a dispute with the eu
commission over customs controls in the
irish sea also out there on the horizon
um will these themselves have economic
implications and how nimble do you
expect london to be
i don't think london has much room for
maneuver um and even you know this whole
simon mentioned the whole sort of
leveling up you know
higher skilled labor should be promoted
and we want to move away from the low
wages and low skilled jobs but i mean
some jobs in the economy are low skilled
you know and they will always be because
that's necessary and you can't just sort
of do without so that's one thing as for
the room for maneuver i don't think
london has a lot i mean they have to
abide by the the brexit
agreement
um
you know they are they are the smaller
they are the david uh against the
goliath and um and and it's actually
it's hard to understand why you know
with the fisherman's licenses why would
they risk a fight over this but you know
yes i mean i would just point out david
um did rather well against goliath
you can um you can certainly tell the
story that's the one they want to tell i
think the eu
um if i could offer a piece of advice
should be should be careful in these
kind of disputes you mentioned this one
over fishing
um
because it's very easy then for the
brexit supporters uh to continue telling
that narrative look here's the the big
clunky eu that wants to bind us in with
their regulations of course this is pure
populism i see that but uh you know it's
much better to diffuse these uh kind of
tensions as i think the european
commission is trying to do but does does
the you actually have to care basically
britain's not going to rejoin the eu for
a couple of decades
if actually playing a tough line towards
the uk on fishing for example is popular
among eu citizens who happen to live in
france why not
look at what's happening in northern
ireland economically speaking the only
part of the uk that hasn't got a fuel
crisis hasn't got a supermarket shelf
shortage is northern ireland because it
works to have a close relationship with
the with the european union and so
finally perhaps a good thing from brexit
as far as the eu is concerned is it
doesn't actually have to listen to the
whining euroskeptics in the uk anymore
and actually it can side with european
citizens who actually say actually we
think that defending eu interests
vis-a-vis the uk maybe that's not the
worst thing that's what i meant there's
not much room for maneuver i mean you
know they are the losing end of the
equation in my view i agree i i'd like
to pick up on the word relationship and
uh take us a little bit further abroad
because with brexit a done deal the uk
is now looking for a new role and new
friends
one thing is clear britain's global
position depends on new alliances in
both security and trade
in a move reminiscent of a james bond
movie great britain and the u.s snatched
a lucrative deal from the nato partner
france securing the license to build
submarines for australia
a prestigious success for boris johnson
in his search for new allies
the deal to modernize australia's fleet
of nuclear-powered vessels is a key
building block of orcas the new
indo-pacific alliance between australia
the uk and the us against china
french president macron was furious
about this and he wasn't the only one
china britain's biggest trading partner
since brexit was also enraged
this makes it all the more urgent for
britain to find new trading partners
but regardless of the submarine deal u.s
president joe biden has made it known
that a trade agreement with britain is
not a priority for him at the moment
british conservatives are therefore
pinning their hopes on kansak a free
trade zone between great britain new
zealand and canada
is the united kingdom really better off
with its new partners than it was with
the eu
the submarine deal simon has given a
post brexit britain a moment in the sun
and it's being portrayed by the
government by boris johnson as proof
that global britain is a vision that is
attainable
absolutely in his uh conference speech
boris johnson said this is the prime
example of what britain can do
outside the european union interesting
that it's a it's a deal
that really has defense implications
it's um
much less easy to see it as a it's not
it's not it's not a free trade deal for
instance with the us and australia um
it's a defense cooperation arrangement
and he said it's all about dealing with
the challenges from china and the
indo-pacific and so on but he he
highlighted it as the thing that
britain can now do is it seeks to have
sort of more global penetration i hope
there aren't more uh
that that's not the tenor of britain's
global role in future is to be a sort of
military power projecting in every
direction but it's very interesting that
that's where
we're seeing brexit happen
john we can do better alone was a very
popular slogan during the pro-brexit uh
campaign which clearly and it's a slogan
clearly targeting europe but not
english-speaking friends like the us and
canada and australia as we heard in the
report so how reliable are these
alliances especially when it comes to
trade can they really replace the old
torn ties to the eu i don't think they
can and if you look at the statistics
we're pretty certain that they can't but
this was a very convenient campaigning
slogan during the brexit referendum if
it may if we have a harder trade
relationship which is a necessary price
for trade with the eu then we can
compensate for trade with our old
friends the commonwealth countries
canada new zealand and australia now
trading with three countries that are
comparatively small and two of which are
on the other end of the world
is not an easy change to make it doesn't
make economic sense and indeed actually
at least in trading some goods some
trade relationships with australia and
new zealand are reasonably close already
so ultimately this was more of a
campaigning device than an actual
workable plan for the post-brexit
economic relationships uh that the uk
wants to have
vendeline coming back to the dispute
that we were talking about just before
the report over the brexit protocol and
the irish sea and it's a very
complicated matter but
is boris johnson essentially playing
chicken here with the eu commission and
if so who do you think will blink first
oh that's a good question
um how to tell i think ultimately boris
johnson will probably blink first as he
has done on so many issues you know and
and and even you know his his agreement
was worse than the one
theresa may had negotiated so i think if
you ask me like this i think he will
blink first
simon is that just simply a sign of his
nimbleness
well
certainly the british government's
saying it's you know
over the next couple of weeks they're
going to talk about um potentially
ripping up the northern ireland protocol
trying to renegotiate one i don't know
on past performance whether it'll
whatever they might come up with would
be better than what they've got now um
just to the point
before you know why should the eu care i
think in the case of ireland northern
ireland uh they really do care because
peace in ireland for everyone is a
paramount concern absolutely but on that
point the british government hasn't
dealt with exactly that problem which is
essentially to say you've got to work
out where you put a border one way or
another for the eu a hard border in
ireland is unacceptable
the british government didn't want to
border in the irc but that's what
they've got and they've refused to
accept
honestly that that's what their deal has
has resulted in and then if we bring it
back to the economic questions
economically there's a deeper economic
integration between northern ireland and
ireland and so therefore economically
right the the whole island economy is
still working comparatively well right
so
economic growth in northern ireland is
stronger than in other parts of the uk
just now and so therefore
is this really as big a problem as boris
johnson wants to make out actually the
northern ireland solution is working
brexit for the rest of the uk so for
england wales and scotland is where the
problems are let me ask you this uh
because the clock is running down uh on
our show it's also running down on
britain's first year outside of europe
our title was brexit boris brexit
boomerang and i'd like to ask all of you
even if a majority on the basis of the
economic implications of all the
different things we're talking about
does conclude that brexit was a mistake
is there any going back vendeline where
do you see britain heading now as this
first year outside of europe ends
i think britain britain will
continue on its present course first of
all um the prime minister very family in
his saddle and he's not going to to to
go back on on you know all the
i mean the course he set the country on
however i could imagine in 20 30 40
years you know but that's that's in the
longer term there might be a move back
to europe but not in the next 10 years
simon
well i don't think the i think the
british government and increasingly the
british people probably are moving on
from brexit it's it's a done deal as
they say and what they the
government talks about now is a
generation you know it'll take a
generation before we see the results the
successes as they tell them uh and
obviously the the um failures as other
people would see it so you'll have to
wait
uh if you want the answer as it were
john simon seems to be buying the boris
johnson rhetoric there to say that it's
a done deal i think that brexit as a
whole is not in question what seems to
be happening is the kind of
how it's carried out the details are
starting to be called into some sort of
a question right like that's been really
shown by these shortages in supermarkets
and in the fueling stations and so
therefore there needs to be some kind of
new relationship for britain with the eu
but on the outside and at the moment no
one other than boris johnson is even
trying to articulate that there's no
opposition really the labour party is
not really making headway to put forward
some kind of an alternative so i agree
that there's no viable prospect of
britain rejoining the eu for some
decades but something has to change in
the relationship because it can't stay
as sort of unstable or tense as is the
case currently our title also asked is
the uk spiraling into a chaos vendeline
last word are we likely to see a chaotic
2022 for britain i think we'll see quite
a tough winter i mean you know there may
not be enough turkeys for christmas and
um so and and you know the gas price and
the fuel price are very high and that's
tough in particular for the poorest in
society so i think the winter will be it
will be possibly a winter of discontent
it will be a very tough winter and a
very difficult 2022. thank you very much
to all of you for being with us on to
the point and thanks to all of you out
there for tuning in see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you